let's bring in former hawaii democratic
congresswoman former presidential
candidate and army reservist tulsi
gabbard she's just back from deployment
in africa to go after al-qaeda affiliate
jihadist there uh congresswoman thanks
for joining us
hey brett i want to talk about
afghanistan foreign policy and
counterterrorism but i want to start on
the issue of immigration that's pressing
now in the news you tweeted out this
today
you said the biden harris open door
policy has been a disaster it needs to
end now the main beneficiaries of open
borders are the gangs cartels and human
traffickers the trump policy of having
people wait on the other side of the
border worked and needs to be reinstated
your your thoughts about what's
happening in del rio and how the
administration is handling it
it is an utter disaster and failure and
it's directly attributed to the biden
harris administration's open border
policy this is not only a humanitarian
crisis it is a national security crisis
and it's something i've said
all along which is that if we do not
secure our borders
then we can't have a secure nation
there are so many issues that that have
happened under this administration that
have led to this point and their
continued failure of leadership is
exacerbating the crisis that we're
seeing play out before our very eyes
but do you think having been in congress
that congress can deal with this issue
congress has proven unfortunately to put
partisan politics ahead of actually
passing
real uh necessary immigration policy
reform but what we've seen under the
last several months under this
administration unfortunately and joe
biden is a friend i hold no malice
towards him but i have to say that the
the policies and decisions that have
been made via executive order by the
white house have led to this open border
policy with thousands tens of thousands
of people coming and and attempting to
and sometimes successfully streaming
across the border and you think that's a
national security threat as well
it absolutely is how can you say that
it's not when we have no idea who is
coming across the border and once again
how can we ensure safety and security
for the american people when we don't
have a secure border all right the
counterterrorism fight the president
talking about how it's evolving how it's
going to change take a listen
we'll meet terrorist threats that arise
today in the future with a full range of
tools available to us we're better
equipped to detect to prevent terrorist
threats
and we are more resilient in our ability
to repel them
and to respond
there are a lot of people a
congresswoman who say
what happened in afghanistan and what is
happening now and how we handled it has
really opened the door for more
terrorists you've just come back from
africa which is also a hotbed of radical
jihadists
your thoughts are where we are
well as as you know brett in both east
and west africa there is a surge of
these jihadist terrorists al-qaeda isis
and affiliated groups
are increasing in their strength
the withdrawal from afghanistan is
something that i agreed with but
unfortunately the way that this
administration
executed that withdrawal has been an
utter and abject disaster which is
continuing to play out as we speak
for those who say and we should continue
to monitor afghanistan to make sure that
there are no al-qaeda and isis
strongholds that are allowed to start to
take root if we're seeing that that's
starting to happen then we need to go
and take them out but we should not be
under the illusion that this is a
problem that's only limited to
afghanistan and the proof of that is
that al qaeda for a very long time has
has
been able to get refuge and actually
have training camps and and support in
pakistan which is a problem that not
only hasn't been addressed but
we've seen the united states continue to
support pakistan
in spite of this known fact and reality
so this is a bigger issue here
that really needs to be addressed
are you still a democrat
yes
and will continue to be despite the
criticism on a number of fronts
well look i i've never been about party
politics brett uh i i think you know
that about me i'm about putting country
first and the problems that we're seeing
on a whole host of policy fronts is
those in positions of power and
leadership putting partisan politics
their own selfish desire for power ahead
of the interests of the country ahead of
the interests of the people and that is
that's what i always try to do my very
best uh in in looking at different
policies is we have to put the people
and the interests of our country first
well i want to ask you about this you
know we're just getting the tip of the
iceberg about this john durham
investigation and there has been an
indictment of a hillary clinton attorney
mr sussman about
basically infusing this russia
narrative
with the help of various media outlets
and others
and it may go other places we don't know
we're following it but you have a unique
perspective in that hillary clinton once
called you a rush russian asset
just to remind people take a listen
they're also going to do third party
again and
i'm not making any predictions but i
think they've got their eye on somebody
who's currently in the democratic
primary
and are grooming her to be the third
party candidate she's a favorite of the
russians yeah she's a russian asset i
mean totally and so
they know they can't win without a third
party candidate
they went on to confirm that that was
you that she was referring to
your thoughts as we're starting to get
this durham investigation and what that
means
confirms what i've known to be true
which is that you have
the power elite people like hillary
clinton those around her
working with
the media the deep state in order to
bring down the destruction and downfall
of anyone that they deem to be a threat
to their power
outsiders people like me people like
donald trump doesn't matter democrat or
republican if they identify hey this is
someone who's not going to toe the line
this is someone who's not gonna
follow kind of the establishment way of
things that are accepted
they pose a threat and we will do they
they will do all they can to silence or
censor or cancel
what they view to be a threat and so
this is bigger than than about me or
trump or anyone else this is actually a
threat to our country and our democracy
and and the arrogance that these people
have in thinking they have the right to
manipulate the american people what they
view what they hear what they see
all to preserve their own selfish
interests not caring at all about the
impact on the country the impact of the
american people or who gets hurt along
the way
it's always interesting to hear your
point of view welcome back anytime thank
you hey sean hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else